Batman and Superman are two of DC Comics
most popular superheroes as members of
the Justice League they formed a strong
sense of respect and friendship with
each other but the two heroes will
finally appear on big screen together in
Batman of a Superman
the only problem they're not gonna be
getting along too well here are five
things you should know before seeing the
film the first time the two met in a
full-length comic was in 1952 Superman
number 76 both Clark Kent and Bruce
Wayne had decided to take a vacation and
go on a cruise the ship was overcrowded
so the two had to share a room this was
a concern for both since they each had a
secret to maintain when a robbery and
fire take place near the dock Bruce
suggests turning off the lights so he
can turn in in the dark both guys figure
they can change into their superhero
identities and fortunately the light
from the flames outside lights up the
room and they both discover each other's
secret there have been other versions of
the first encounter throughout the years
in the movie we know during Superman's
fight with General Zod a Wayne financial
building was destroyed killing hundreds
of employees inside the threat of
Superman's power is what makes Batman
decide to take on Superman even though
they've become great friends in the
comics that two superheroes have fought
many many times
the most notable fight was in 1986 The
Dark Knight Returns by Frank Miller this
story is set twenty years into the
future
showing the ultimate showdown between
the former allies when the world changed
and heroes took on a different stance on
fighting evil another time was when
poison id2 control of Superman and
commands him to fight Batman Batman uses
a kryptonite ring and other weapons
against him the two have also fought in
the animated Batman Superman movie in
1997 as well as numerous other comics
despite having a movie Center on two
heroes fighting Batman and Superman have
actually formed a strong friendship in
the comics the kryptonite ring Batman
used against Superman originally
belonged to Lex Luthor Superman
entrusted it with Batman to be used if
he ever went out of control and needed
to be stopped
Wonder Woman first appeared in 1941 saw
Star Comics number 8 with her origin
fleshed out more in 1942 s Wonder Woman
number one Wonder Woman comes from an
island in the Amazons originally her
mother made her out of clay she then
came to life and had incredible
abilities it was recently revealed the
story of her being made from clay was
actually a cover Wonder Woman was
actually the daughter of Zeus and the
story was created to prevent Zeus his
wife Hera from murdering Wonder Woman
out of jealousy Wonder Woman is a
demigod and his thousands of years old
doomsday was created on Krypton in
ancient times scientists sent a baby to
face this vicious creature outside the
remains were cloned and the process was
repeated over and over after over 30
years that baby evolved and no longer
needed to breathe or eat he turned on
his creators and escaped the planet
eventually doomsday was captured and
contained he would later make his way to
earth in battle Superman which resulted
in both of their deaths in the upcoming
film lex luthor obtains Zod's body after
his death at the hands of Superman and
does some experiments of his own this is
likely how dude's day is introduced in
the movie closing this out another thing
you can expect and Batman vs Superman is
plenty of action the movie smashes its
way into theaters on March 25th this
movie will mark the beginning of a
bigger cinematic universe for DC Comics
and were hopefully in for a big treat